[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
can you hear me now yeah
yeah are we back okay so your dad have
more pro bowls than you
yeah yeah yeah he's got six i keep
saying i was like you know in my
household
we go about the jordan men have 11 pro
bowls i've only got five
so you know i'm almost holding my weight
but at least we're double digits
and your dad played tight end for the
vikings uh steve jordan for
over a decade i think yeah 13 seasons
deep
uh 82 82 through 94 you talk about six
pro bowls
um growing up you just don't realize how
great your dad
is until you know high school college
did you go into the locker room do you
remember your first game you went to see
nah i mean i remember being super cold
in some sort of a way game type
situation where you're just miserable
and you're just like i just want to get
out of here
uh get to the car and you know the car
lock the car door is frozen
so it's not what we call fond memories i
mean i got more memories of running
around the training facility and
punching on big punching bags and
you know whatever it is did now your dad
went to brown
did you ever consider going to brown
not at all nothing nothing about the
east coast life is appeasing
to a west coast kid oh really i'm come
on
i'm in arizona you know we used to go
into california all the time
like the the best coast just is just a
better way of life
you got like four seasons on the east
coast i'm not even sure what that's
about
my thickest piece of clothing is a
sweater you know like that it just
doesn't go well
sweats and shorts aren't going to get
you through new york anything uh
you got the game coming up sunday night
with the buccaneers how closely were you
watching the game last night
i did not i did not i'm not going to lie
to you i assumed that
tampa bay was gonna be the giants i
didn't realize it's gonna be a close
game like that
you can't get anything out of a game
like that like that wouldn't be homework
oh for sure i'm gonna break i'm gonna
break down that film because they got
after them um
i mean i saw the highlights uh my kids
won last night so uh
you know monday became an upside down
magic off disney plus
a movie night instead of football that's
good i got three kids they win sometimes
yeah when you go against brady like
is there any surprises no i mean he's
uh he's the the most you know probably
the winningest quarterback that you're
going to see in our era you talk about
six championship rings um that's
undisputed uh he's probably the second
greatest quarterback of all times right
now
drew brees wow um do you really think
that
do you really think that that drew is
about 5 000 yards uh season do you think
that
drew is a better quarterback than tom do
i know that drew is a better quarterback
last ten years of my life tells me
that's being a good teammate what do you
expect out of antonio brown
uh we all know antonio brown when he
hits the field is special um
even in his you know limited playing
times the last
you know whatever two seasons of
whatever was going on he showed up and
showed out at the patriots when he
played so
we know he is a special talent when he
takes the field um that's something that
we'll be
prepped for it's not like they already
didn't have a potent offense to begin
with
what's another piece it seems like every
week they're adding more pieces right
do you know him uh yeah i mean we we
i hate to say it but we share the same
birthday and i always say i hate to say
because i hate to share my birthday with
anybody i don't really
um it doesn't work that way cam like
there's a lot of people in the world
i hear you but i've got friends that
have my birthday and i i
either congratulate them on the 9th or
the 11th not on the 10th
yeah yeah hey man happy early birthday
and i will not tell you the 10th is my
day like
they text me happy birthday camo i
appreciate it and then the next day i'm
like hey same to you happy belated
i'm selfish sorry how would you sum up
this season
um this season for the saints the season
nfl this season because of kovan
that's that's an open question right
there but for the seasons for the saints
uh we're trending upwards i mean sitting
at where we were
um i sitting at five and two you know
after going one and two
it's something that we're we're fighting
we're fighting each and every week to uh
to try and trend upwards we gotta got a
lot of things to overcome and we're
still cleaning up some things
but i like the way we're playing right
now do you have a list
uh whether you actually have one or in
your mind of quarterbacks you've sacked
or haven't sacked no not at all all i
care about is that win column
um personal accolades i worry about in
the off season
after we get done winning um during
season all i care about is trying to get
a super bowl
as you said you know me and pop's got 11
pro bowls 23 years of nfl experience
between us now
we have no super bowls i'm just trying
to win
have you sacked brady
yes look for verbal confirmation
yes so it wasn't memorable then
uh i mean not at all i remember my first
sack
and i remember my last sack who's the
toughest guy
toughest guy to bring down um
i mean i thought that clearly it's cam
newton uh cam newton
in his whole carolina uh panthers
career um he's bigger what he's bigger
they're gonna get faster they're gonna
get
there is probably no other quarterback
that's as hard to take down
especially when he's rolling um ben
roethlisberger is huge
you know russell wilson
russell wilson might be my my white
buffalo i don't think i sacked him now
that i think
i think about it but i mean russell
wilson is fast
lamar jackson is fast but cam newton has
has all of it
do any of these guys talk to you do i
talk to them absolutely
do they talk back no i mean but who are
you talking
but what are you trying to get out of
them i'm just trying to rile the
feathers up you know like
at some at some point you're just
looking like how can i how can i try and
affect them
but they know like if you're the face of
the franchise you're getting you're
getting compensated well
you're probably playing well and you
know one stack or two sacks three sex
you know
down the line four sacks call it you
know all you're gonna do is to start
talking to your office of lineman you're
not even gonna talk to your defensive
end after like i try and get chippy
then at this point i realize
quarterbacks are just good people
would you rather face a rookie tackle or
rookie quarterback
i'd rather face a quarterback who's
gonna sit in the pocket and pat that
ball a couple times and make smart deci
you know make the smart decisions not
just the first decision
you got rookie quarterbacks who come in
and know how to air it out and get the
ball out of their hands fast
i'd rather let have a quarterback sit at
nine yards
and try and get to their second or third
read ever
ever come close to hitting brees uh
in practice yeah a couple times um i i
doubt i'll ever get that chance to
actually set drew
it hurts it hurts i mean we talked about
it in practice i'm like god have been
one no
cam i would have got out there
like i just need to fold you one time
like but it's okay
that's my guy what the heck is going on
with michael thomas is he playing sunday
night
uh that's a michael thomas question um
i'm not saying it's above my pay grade
but that's coming from a higher spot
than where i'm sitting do you
expect him to play sunday night i expect
mike t to play whenever
uh he's told that he will be playing um
in terms of what mike t brings to the
game i can't wait till he gets back to
being played
um in my mind you know i hope it's the
pr staff
next to you cameron no
can you just ask him just say hey uh is
is michael thomas going to play
this weekend just ask him right now he's
not even looking he's not even looking
at you but you can he
you can get his attention it's
yeah he's not he's not coming up
[Laughter]
at this point you know when mike t takes
the field just know he's gonna be he's
gonna be right enough to
uh to take over all right uh what are
you doing with your new foundation
uh the goddess love foundation i mean
we're in so many different things you
know we talk about
hurricane season um and how it's
affected louisiana um from delta to
laura to now
you know zeta that just passed through
new orleans i mean i saw the eye of a
hurricane you know last week with my
kids you know we went outside i was like
hey that's
this is live hurricane apparently it's
only happened like four four times in
the last hundred years in new orleans
um so we saw that and then went back
inside uh but
how many people are affected by these
hurricanes so we started up a little fun
with the united way um to get money out
to uh
lake charles and the affected areas um
and honestly you know we've got a couple
things in the works now with the uh the
city of new orleans
uh which will be unveiled probably the
next month or so uh
we've gone through tech funds gone
through you know diaper funds this covid
has affected so many
so many people um throughout our nation
throughout the world at this point
but controlling what you can't control
trying to affect what you can't affect
uh my city of new orleans you know i'm
always i'm always looking and trying to
do something for them
yeah youth empowerment project uh
mentorship program in new orleans it's
called
cam jordan's dream builders fun you also
got a podcast with
mark ingram hey no no better person to
have
some fun with than your brother you know
we came into the saints together we
played uh eight years deep together and
uh that's my brother from another it's
like you know we blood but we not blood
that's my guy he's funny so he's a
character hey we started it up and i
mean we just started calling friends
around the league and just had it had a
blast for
for a few episodes and we're releasing
you know every every wednesday
so we'll drop one tomorrow tomorrow
because today today is important for
voting
and that's what i need everybody to
focus on voting tomorrow we'll have more
fun
you're going to run for office one day
office of
uh being a dad of three almost four now
yes
that's it i'm gonna have a soccer van
a mom soccer van which in my mind is
escalating now um
wifey said she would be on the soccer
van so she's got to escalate so i just i
was like i'll take that over when you
know i retire babe
uh i like it and then whatever whatever
it takes to do but at this point i feel
like i've got about five years left of
football
and i got to make each one of these
years count i gotcha you know how many
sacks you have
89 and a half regular season another
five and a half playoffs
you don't keep track of your sax huh ah
no
no i think that's really my problem is
this year is the first year where i've
been like
i'm actually within my goals reach um
normally i worry about you know sack
sack totals all that other stuff after
season
and i'm getting back to that mentality
uh because when you think about like
that grand picture like i'm this close
to 100 sacks like 100 sacks is such a
marquee
uh note a goal that you can actually
capitalize and realize upon
it it takes away from you know it sort
of takes away so
your focus just a little bit uh just in
just in terms of how thirsty you get
during the game like i need this act
like i need the second i need the sack
and then instead of letting the sacks
present themselves these
well you got five pro balls if you get a
couple more pro bowls and you get over
100 sacks you get 115 120 sacks and all
of a sudden
you're kind of knocking on the door
can't i'm probably knocking on the door
cannon now oh
but that's that's not me
[Laughter]
that's not on me that's on you know
whoever uh okay whoever goes and decides
that
you think you're a hall of famer right
now i always think in my mind that i
come out to be the best all-around
defensive end of the game
um and i think i've proven that over the
last five years or so
uh it's not the saks it's not you know
just playing
playing the pass i play the run i play
the pass and
i play second down too i don't i want to
play all
if there's 78 snaps in the game all the
snaps in the game i want to be the best
every play every game that i take the
field on it's great to catch up with you
again we always appreciate it thanks for
joining us have fun against uh brady and
the buccaneers
hey appreciate it hey all we gotta do is
get one percent better every day
trending upwards that's all we care
about
that's uh cameron jordan he doesn't have
as many pro bowls as his dad
steve jordan had six cam has five